hey guys it's justine and today we're
checking out the new dji om5 om5 osmo
mobile you may know this line of phone
stabilizers by many different things
whatever you know it as this is the new
one this looks so cool it looks so much
smaller than all of the previous
versions and i'm very interested to test
out this little antenna feature like
check that out i've been shooting so
much more content on my phone recently
because i've actually been getting out
of the house i've been doing a little
more traveling and i've been filming a
lot of tick tocks and sometimes filming
vertical content just shooting it
directly on your phone is so much easier
than getting out a massive camera and
the quality on phones these days is so
amazing and adding a stabilizer like
this to your phone whether it's an
android or an iphone it's just gonna set
your content apart from anything else
let's open this up check it out and
freaking go to hawaii baby
so some of the highlights we have shot
guides we have a three axis
stabilization active track foldable and
portable a magnetic design
and a built-in extension rod
oh
look at you here we go
here it is
oh my gosh this is so light this is so
incredibly light holy moly wow
whoa
dude oh freaking this is gonna be so
much fun i cannot wait my tick tock game
and my instagram reels and my youtube
shorts game like i'm gonna be able to
film in space elon hello yeah you might
have a rocket well guess what i have i
have the ohm five okay have you seen
anything like this no this is technology
that you don't even know anything about
even that feels lighter
it just clamps right on to the device
and then if you want to take your phone
off if you need to like send a text
message or do whatever like you just go
like that you can take it off
got a little carrying string which i
love
charging cable
love to see that as well here's a little
riser pad for smaller phones
this is great this is a little tripod
now i love dji not only because they
make really great products but the
software that goes along with them is
what really makes these so powerful
because they're able to really elevate
and take advantage of these incredible
products with their software
oh
a little pouch oh hello say no more
into the pouch you go
look at that
right in
little bag
oops forgot our cable
okay now we're ready to go
okay so this says
phone camera direction so
here
like so
and then
there we go okay i'm gonna turn this on
and it's probably gonna freak out
oh look at that you're already doing it
look at you doing your job i haven't
even charged you or installed the app
and you're already
working look at that look at this look
at this look at this oh dude this is so
great
i can't believe it i feel like i'm like
in some sort of pixar movie like i'm i'm
wally i'm gonna look like such
a freaking tourist everywhere i go and
i'm so here for it okay let's go get
some content
[Music]
wow this is squishy
oh boy i'm testing out the dji ohm 5.
i'm so excited about this because it's
honestly so much lighter and smaller and
slimmer than the previous version so i'm
out on this hike
and it's like i'm basically holding
nothing it's so light
[Music]
there she is it's jenna's birthday today
the thing that i love so much about this
is the iphone is already so smooth and
steady so being able to add this
additional stabilization to it it almost
makes it seem
like a drone is following you
[Music]
so
so you might realize i'm not in hawaii
because
uh my car got broken into and i lost the
footage yeah um so we're in santa monica
anyway i'm really excited about this
because obviously i'm such a huge fan of
mobile filming and this just kind of
gives you that extra little steadiness
that you need and the other thing that i
really like i showed you this in my
unboxing is this
[Applause]
surprise you can now get like a whole
another angle
like look how high i am i mean i look
like such a tourist in my own town i'm
right now the kind of person that gets
made fun of but you know what
i don't care look at this this is great
if you guys are familiar with dji
software then you might be familiar with
active track
[Music]
so we did that that's active track big b
let's test out a piano photo here
and this is cool because it's going to
take a bunch of photos and stitch them
all together
there it goes
[Music]
oh yeah that looks cool
all right
i really want to try the cloney pano
this is going to be cool it'll basically
stitch me together and clone me three
times i just have to physically move my
body i'm gonna hit record
[Music]
it's beautiful
this
i think should be my first nft i'm gonna
do one more just because the lighting is
better this way and if i'm gonna make
this my first nft i gotta have a
follow-up
[Music]
god that's art
i might have to give that to like the
moma or something i look like an idiot
it's
incredible so now i'm gonna test out the
story mode i'm actually gonna have tyler
help me film this but it's really cool
because they give you a ton of these
little templates and then it'll show you
the shot that you have how many seconds
you have to film it and then it'll
automatically edit you together a cool
little montage i think i'm gonna do this
one it's called rhythm rotate with beats
tyler are you ready
i'm gonna pass this off to you
the future of this is in your hands
yeah you flip the camera yeah just
careful that don't hold that there don't
do that um yeah
this is great it automatically edited
everything together to music to the beat
this is gonna be my third nft i can't
believe i got so many nfts today this is
wild hit record
when you're moving in and then
and you're
moving
any white christian
moving out
any white american
[Applause]
dino zoom is another feature you select
your desired effect you move out or move
in depending upon which one you want to
do so we're going to test both of these
out first up let's do the move out
[Music]
oh this is cool
it's just using the digital zoom oh this
one's super zoomed in
nice
that looks cool so i have two more
features to test out there's a
hyperlapse and a time lapse so this
weekend i'm going to shoot a couple of
those and i'm going to send those over
to tyler you just put them right here
[Music]
the sun has gone down the moon is about
to come up and long ago somebody left
with a cup and i have attached this
really cool phone mount this has a
built-in light i love this additional
accessory that's available it's a little
phone mount with a built-in selfie light
it's really great because you can adjust
the color temperature and you can even
adjust the brightness by three levels
there's a button right here on the back
to turn it on and to adjust the
brightness and the button here on the
bottom to adjust the color temperature
oh hey welcome back from that really fun
hyperlapse time lapse adventure i've
been having so much fun testing this out
and i really love that this is so much
lighter i love that they added this
extension pool which can give you an
all-new vantage point i hope you guys
enjoyed this video i had a lot of fun
making it i'll put a link in the
description if you want to check this
out to get more information or purchase
it and with that i'll see you guys in my
next video like comment subscribe hit
the bell
yeah that's that's all the things see
you later
[Music]
you